the NFL made a big headline yesterday
Shireen with the news that over the next
10 years the NFL will donate two hundred
and fifty million dollars to combat
systemic racism and that is a huge
headline that is a big deal two hundred
and fifty million dollars or the cost of
Jerry Jones yacht either way a quarter
of a billion dollars is a quarter of a
billion dollars there's no other way to
cut it but and you know we did the math
and our good friend Amy Trask did the
math and others did the math and when
you do the math over ten years with 32
teams it's and and this is not a
criticism and Amy trask made the mistake
of I think last night trying to respond
to every single person who was attacking
her for being critical it's not a
criticism it's a fact it's a fact 781228
great but when you break it down it's
we're talking about billion-dollar
businesses here we're not talking about
all that much money per team per year
being thrown into the pot to fix this
problem I think first we start Mike with
kudos big number glad they did it you
had to do something besides the words
the the Goodell video was great it was a
step you had to take that next step
which was given money but let's go back
they did the same thing two years ago
and we did the same figures and it was
about the same amount of money
I like the teams that are going a step
further and also given money the
Minnesota Vikings for instance have
given five million dollars they
announced that earlier this week and
some other teams have given some money
and the Vikings have started the George
Floyd a scholarship 125 thousand dollars
so you know various teams are doing
things so kudos to them for doing all
this but yes when you talk about what
these billion dollar owners make off of
the NFL off of what they do this is a
drop in the bucket for them it's a step
but still more needs to be done but let
us start there and it's a step that's
part of a formula and it's a formula
that we've become familiar with issue
statement
money issues statement throw money and
it's fine look the money will be helpful
I'm sure but in this moment this is the
point where the old rulebook gets ripped
up and I think that what people are
looking for is authenticity what people
are looking for is something more raw
something more real something that
reflects a true acknowledgment of the
problem that has been hiding in plain
sight for decades if not centuries and
in awakening not just a statement not
just a cheque but something that proves
that everything is dramatically
different than it was and when we look
around elsewhere look no farther than
what NASCAR did one fell swoop get the
Confederate flag Confederate flag the
hell out of here gone get it out of here
for good the kind of thing that that is
jarring and the kind of thing that
speaks to the awakening that so many
people are having and when I see the
same old formula from the NFL it's like
look hey look at that video was great
even though it didn't match completely
what the players wanted and I think it
would have been better if it would have
been a montage of owners to match the
montage of players if only they had a
employee in the in the league who could
put that oh wait they do that's the guy
who put together the one for the players
and went rogue to do it but but look it
hasn't been perfect but but the
statement was was good and it was Roger
Goodell's finest moment but what you do
after that is what's important and the
old formula of throw money at it and
make a statement and get some good PR
points I don't know that that is the way
to go anymore
no and you know we're gonna talk about a
lot of things they can do and I think
one thing that that would go a long way
that we don't have our list to talk
about is the national anthem if there
are protests the league to support that
back that up you know Jerry Jones has
said repeatedly back that toes on the
line my guys are going to stand for the
national anthem and they have the
Cowboys are one of the only teams that
haven't protested this thing so far but
times have changed this feels different
it's a movement it's a change things are
different now on the league and so they
need to come out
support the players in whatever way they
want a protest and if that's Nealon from
the national anthem and that's Nederland
for the national anthem but there needs
to be around the league solid support
for the players in whatever they want to
do however they want to protest whatever
they want to say they need to use their
platforms as Patrick mahomes pointed out
this week and you're absolutely right
and that's something that Sims and I
talked about earlier in the week that it
can't be the coach who says I support my
guys or the coach who says we're going
to make a team decision look team
decision dilutes the will of the
individual the individual gets overcome
by the team dynamic and the the desires
of the coach of the team leaders end up
trickling down to everyone else even if
that's what they don't want to do what I
have said is every owner and this would
be a perfect opportunity for a montage
of video every owner needs to say not
just it's okay or you know that kind of
passive tolerance that we saw a couple
of years ago it needs to be a clear
affirmative statement that I want every
member of the organization to make a
conscious decision as to what is the
appropriate thing to do during the
national anthem
whether it's kneel sit stand or
something else and I want you to make
that decision and I want you to I
encourage you to make the decision I
encourage you to do the thing that you
feel in your heart you should do and I
support you completely and there will be
no repercussions you will not be cut
because of it you will not be benched
because of it your playing time won't be
limited because of it you won't get a
new contract because of it we support
you and we want you to make this
decision we want you to implement the
decision that is in your heart that's
the kind of clarity because otherwise it
feels reluctant it feels like well yeah
you know we wrote that policy and it's
got a doughnut hole in it that we
probably shouldn't have put in there and
it says should stand instead of must
stand and the lawyers have gotten
involved now and the unions involved so
we got to let we got to let them stand
if they want to stand it can't be that
it's got to be stronger I think you're I
think you're on to something there
absolutely Mike and and you know this
this Jerry Jones needs to talk needs to
come out and we're gonna talk a little
bit more about that later on but the
owners do need to speak out and
their voices need to be loud and they
need to be as one to say we support you
we support you players however you want
to protest whatever you want to do in
this league it is fine by us and there
can't be any repercussions for this
which is what they tried to do a couple
years ago and you know as it turns out I
Colin Kaepernick obviously was right and
everybody should listen a lot sooner
than what they have listened but they're
listening now and I think that's the
point moving forward it's got to be more
and they've got to listen even more to
their players and whatever their players
want they've got to say okay you're
right
we'll let you have it so the official
list of things that the owners can do I
think we can expand to three and things
work better in threes item one make a
clear statement of unconditional support
or whatever any player chooses to do
during the anthem owners need to do it
not coach is not the commissioner no one
else the owners need to do it all 32
need to do it period
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports